we are overdue
for our continuation of the x-men film
franchise and that brings us to x-men
first class
now normally i'm not big on prequels
they've got a lot of inherent issues one
of them being we know where these
characters are going to end up later so
it takes a lot of the stakes out despite
my reservations this actually turned out
really well and was a really important
step for the franchise in a lot of ways
the first being the omission of
wolverine it was really important that
there finally be a film that establishes
x-men as a franchise does not begin and
end with wolverine because he'd been the
focus of every single film let's get the
focus back on professor x and magneto as
i pointed out when i talked about the
first x-men film there are a lot more
continuity issues with this than i had
initially thought when watching the
continuity errors are not the fault of
this film and actually i gotta say they
they ultimately made the right call to
accept certain continuity errors
for the sake of telling a better story
things like where professor xavier said
that he met a magneto as a teenager and
obviously we're seeing them meet for the
first time in their 30s so there's those
sorts of decisions being made set
continuity errors aside this is a really
tight film and there's not too much to
complain about here they make really
good use of the period setting that sort
of
james bond they're a spy feel that you
kind of get to it that's a really good
thing to pull from it and they avoid all
the 60s cliches of hippies and counter
culture and all that other junk that's
just been done to death
casting
really nicely done because given that
they already had iconic performances
given by patrick stewart and ian
mckellen you need to get really good
actors
actors who are good enough to pick
pieces that will evoke what the other
actors have done so that you can see the
connection but are also confident enough
in themselves to do their own thing so
it's not an impression at any point they
can be younger they can be brashered
they can they can have things different
about the characters because we know
they're gonna go through a lot of
personal changes in a journey i think it
was also a good call not to have too
many recurring characters ones we'd
already seen basically all we've got
we've got professor x and magneto we've
got mystique
that's pretty much it as far as direct
um characters that we've seen before oh
no there is one more um and that's beast
and choosing to have hank mccoy front
and center actually a pretty good call
especially considering we're not gonna
see him go through a physical
transformation until a little after the
halfway mark so he was a good call to
bring back as well pretty much everybody
else though
is all fresh blood which is a really
good idea by filling out the rest of the
x-men team with characters we have not
seen before havoc angel darwin banshee
this gives us the opportunity to throw
in characters where you don't know if
they're gonna make it because we haven't
seen them later on they could very well
die
unfortunately most of these filler
characters feel like just that they feel
like filler characters i'm not sure
there was much that could be done about
that though because the focus really
needs to be so strongly on professor x
and magneto that they were always just
gonna be side characters the action
there's a decent amount of action in
this film but it doesn't feel like an
action film it feels much more
intellectual which is a bit more in line
with x2 so it's nice to be getting that
feeling back as well
um matthew vaughn who came on to direct
this it almost feels like in a way he's
kind of apologizing for x-men the last
stand he's saying look because i left
that film i couldn't guide it into
something better you got stuck with what
you had so here let me apologize and
give you what i hoped i could have given
you if i'd done the last stand effects
are all very good and it's much more
careful use of special effects than we
saw in x-men origins wolverine or in
x-men the last stand it's just a return
to form for the franchise i still
personally like x2 a little bit better
but i think this does give it a run for
its money and anyone who says that first
class is their favorite in the series i
i would not begrudge them that and now
we're going to be getting our sequel
basically to both this and x-men the
last stand in the form of days of future
past it's gonna be really interesting to
see how they pull this off so until next
time this council is adjourned